so far we've dealt with simple chains
and rings of carbons but let's think
about what happens when things get a
little bit more complex let me just draw
a molecule here and we can think about
how we'll name it so let me draw so let
me let me draw it like let me draw it
like that so here we don't have a simple
chain it branches off at some point so
what we do in this situation is we find
the longest chain in this molecule and
let's think about what the longest chain
is if we start here we get one two three
four five six seven eight carbons if we
start here we get one two three four
five six seven eight nine carbons so
what we do is we look at the longest
chain the longest chain is this one
right here let me do this in a different
color so this is one two three one two
three four five six seven eight nine
carbons and so this will be that will be
kind of the core of our naming so it's
nine carbons so that right here longest
chain longest chain has nine carbons you
can kind of view this as the backbone of
our molecule and also the backbone of
our naming nine carbons so we're dealing
with a nonane nan Ain remember nine nan
for nine and then Ain because we're
dealing with an alkane we have all
single bonds over here now what do we do
with this thing over here
well what's kind of sticking off of this
chain well we essentially have we have
one carbon here that's attached to the
chain right this carbon is bonded to a
carbon on the chain if we wanted to draw
the entire molecule we could draw carbon
here and it would it be bonded to three
hydrogen's but that is all implicit but
what is this thing right here well it's
one carbon so you might be tempted to
say it's methane but it's not methane
because attached to other things but it
would be right to use the prefix meth so
this right here you would use the prefix
meth so this is one one carbon
so you would want to use the prefix meth
but because it isn't part of it isn't
the main chain it is added to something
else
we don't write methane we write methyl
so let me write this right here mat fill
methyl so this means this means that it
is it branches off branches off longer
chain longer chain so this this molecule
right here would be called and actually
there's one more thing that we have to
think about this thing could have been
we could just call it methyl nonane let
me just write that down right now so we
could just call this right from the
get-go we could call it methyl methyl na
named methyl nonane but there's one
problem with just calling it methyl Nani
this is methyl nonane but so it's let me
draw it so this thing I just drew here
this is 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so
that's the nonane and the one I drew
here is 1 2 3 the the methyl is right
over here that's what I just drew that
is let me do it the same color so this
is what I just drew but maybe what if it
was something like this what if it was 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and let's say that the
methyl group was instead of being right
here let's say the methyl group was
right here so how would you name these
two things differently this name right
now does not differentiate between the
methyl group being on this carbon versus
the methyl group being on this carbon
over here or this carbon over there and
what you do in this case is you number
the carbons on the longest chain on the
main backbone and you number them so
that the methyl group is attached to the
lowest possible number so there's two
possible ways to number this chain you
could start here is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 then
you would say that this would be the
methyl group is attached to the 7 carbon
or you could start numbering from this
end of the chain would be 1 2 3 or so it
could also be attached to the 3rd 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 so you want to number it so
you're closest to the methyl
so you want to start here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 so in this case this would not just
be methyl nonane this thing right here
would be 3 let me make this very clear
it would be three methyl nonane because
the methyl group that one carbon that
one ch3 is attached to the third carbon
on our nonane backbone so that right
there is three methyl nani since i drew
this out what is this right here well
once again we have this nonane and
backbone 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and you want
a number it so that this methyl group is
at this at the lowest number carbon as
possible so it's closer to this end than
that end so it's 1 2 3 4 I'll do that in
magenta and then you could keep
numbering 5 6 7 8 9 so this one is going
to be this one is going to be 4 and then
you have your methyl group it's just one
carbon sitting right there so for 4
methyl 4 methyl nonane 4 methyl nonane
now let's go let's go the other way
around let's say we start with the name
and we want to figure out its formula
and hopefully this will this this gives
you a good a good understanding how
things will get more complex and over
the next few videos I'll get more and
more complex but you'll see it's all at
least reasonably logical so let's say I
were to give you let's say I were to
give you let's say I were to give you
let me think of one let's say 2 - propyl
propyl heptane - propyl heptane so how
do we how do we take this apart so the
first thing you see it is a it is an
alkane it's all going to be single bonds
heptane this is kind of the core so the
longest chain here kept is the prefix
for seven so this tells us let me make
this clear this tells us that we're
dealing with all single bonds single
bonds single bonds that's what the Ain
tells us if we had double bonds it would
be een triple bonds ein we're going to
see that in the future but let's stay
simple right now the HEPT
tells us that we were dealing with seven
seven carbons seven carbons and then
what does this to propyl means well
propyl propyl tells us what was the what
was the pro prefix if methyl is one
ethyl is two propyl is 3 butyl is four
so this is a three three carbon group
three carbon group and it's going to be
attached to the second carbon on the
heptane so let me draw the heptane chain
so we have seven carbons so one two
three four five six seven and then on
the second carbon on the second carbon
so let me pick a good color here on the
second carbon so if we just number it
one two three four five six seven on the
second carbon right there we have a
propyl group we have a propyl group but
there's a three carbon group so let me
draw the propyl group so we have a 1 2 3
3 carbon group and it's attached at the
second carbon right there so this
molecule to propel heptane looks just
like this let's do another one maybe one
that seems a little bit more more
difficult let's say that we have let's
say that we have six let's say we have
six butyl six butyl tetra decade tetra
deca and all of these might seem a
little daunting when you see it at first
but if you really just break it up it
actually is pretty logical so once again
we have the Ain there so it's called
going to be single bonds
what is tetra deck what is that prefix
well deck is 10 and then we have tetra
that's 4 plus 10 that's 14 tetra deck is
14 so this is telling us that we're
dealing with a 14 carbon chain 14 carbon
chain so let's draw that so 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 carbon chain
and if we number them 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 this tells us that the
sixth the sixth carbon will be butyl
will be a butyl group so let's see the
six carbon is right here and butyl and
you should memorize this methyl is one
at the list - propyl is three butyl is
four so we have a four carbon group so
let me write this in pink maybe so this
is a 4 4 4 carbon group 4 carbon it's
actually called an alkyl group it's it's
attached to something else so on the 6
carbon we have a 4 carbon group so 1 let
me draw it this way no this is fine
let's say it's let's say it's we have 1
2 3 4 so that is our butyl right there
and it's just attached to the sixth
carbon it's attached to the six carbon
right there so this is what our molecule
would look like now let me ask you a
question
would you ever see would you ever see a
nine butyl tetra decade would you ever
see a nine butyl texture decane so
something where so let me redraw it like
this let me so a nine butyl tetra decade
so it would have a butyl over here one
two three four one two three four
would you ever see a nine butyl tetra
decade will you ever see that written
you might say oh yeah the digit Sal you
just drew it and the reason why you
won't ever see that written is because
there's a better way to number it if
it's like this instead of starting over
here at one at this end you'd want to
start one at that end so instead of
saying nine butyl tetra decane you
should number it the other way to say
this is one two three four five six so
this is actually also six butyl tetra
decane I'm sure I got that that one two
three four five six so instead of going
instead of starting from the left and
making this the ninth carbon you always
want to start numbering from the
direction that has a lowest number for
the first group